it's morphin time that's right Logan
wasn't the only movie they got a trailer
this weekend we have a new trailer for
Power Rangers and had the Kanye song in
it we all know that that's reserved for
the good ones but it's established in
the trailers like we're misfits we don't
really know each other but we all came
together proof positive to Breakfast
Club are the Power Rangers then they
find the command center which in this
movie is a ship that's buried
underground then they find the power
coins and Bryan Cranston's floating head
and they talk and then when they're in
the pool they're all peeing in the pool
and they're paying different colors and
they're like a we're going to be
skittles Power Rangers which is Power
Rangers prime it shows that they have
their powers even when they're not in
the suit in which case what the point of
this is maybe the suits will make them
more powerful but they're like amazing
spider-man you know like punching their
sinks and breaking their [ __ ] jumping
really far there's so much more light on
this side because my window is open
right now is sunny I usually film at
night so it's like light shed
you see alpha which in the trailer alpha
didn't bother me I saw the concept art
from the movie and I was like alpha
looks like a crazy little creep robot
I'll stick in his pelvis out like he's
the creepy uncle Hey ladies
there's one for me it wasn't so bad Ryan
cranes gonna be great at auradon now
he's probably going to have minimal I
think 78% of the lines he has in the
movie we probably heard in this trailer
he's been in power injuries before yeah
did you know that in Mighty Morphin
Power Rangers the TV show
Bryan Cranston voiced a couple of the
monsters just came out to fight Power
Rangers you're like you knew that but if
you didn't know that now you know that
and after that CGI rage destruction Rita
and things crumbling and big rocks
monsters and Zords and gold arm pretty
sure it was just this big golden monster
coming out to look that's a lot of gold
and look at that gold arm but you do
know what this movie is good a bit as
part of it is like it looks cheesy it
looks like cheesy fun now remember it's
Power Rangers Mighty Morphin Power
Rangers as endearing as it is as much as
it is a part of my past and something
that I can still watch and enjoy because
it takes me back it's cheesy
so the movies cheesy I guess it's pretty
part with the chorus the main thing I'm
scared of it I don't want it to be a
case where they all come together find
this stuff then they're like oh we're
going to be Power Rangers but they're
not actually Power Rangers until the
very end of the movie I don't want them
to be teenagers who can run and jump far
and that's all they do I want to see
them morph out and become Power Rangers
and do a couple things leading up to the
big battle with the Zords at the end but
we didn't see a bit of the action with
the Zords which said didn't movies
credit it is
hang on it looks like the Zords are
going to individually fight in the
gorilla alright that's not really
getting it done let's become the
Megazord from the show I mean a couple
episodes aside where they actually did
fight one-on-one before they turn into
Megazord generally it was like bring up
the Zords let's turn it right in the
Megazord man who are we kidding we know
that's where it's going to go I do want
to see Rita once the Elizabeth Banks
just say the line magic wand make my
gold art grow cause any in the Power
Rangers trail I didn't blow me away
honestly I wasn't like we're going to
see you now probably because it came out
the same day the Logan trailer did and
I'm pretty much I'm Logan right now it's
like Logan's in my head however the
trailer itself does look fine it does
look like a fun movie cheesy
yeah I gotta go with it alright guys so
the new Power Rangers trailer have you
seen it why can you think about it what
do you think the movies going to be like
you think you're going to like it if you
like Power Rangers when you were little
does it look like it's going to
translate well whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you seen here and you
want to see more click right here to say
more
[Music]